I've talked to Trump maybe more recently
than ever same guy
but I don't agree with him I don't agree
with the pulling out of our troops out
of Syria and abandoning the Kurds I
don't agree with the down way we're
pulling out of Afghanistan at the time I
didn't want 5 000 troops but I thought
1200 was fine I disagree with him
um on a few things and he didn't like
that but I think he respected it but the
audience goes crazy especially early
when you disagree with what the
president's doing that you know General
Mattis is not a bad General it's not a
good thing to say I like people that
didn't get captured doesn't mean I hate
Trump but I am not going to pretend to
saying that about John McCain was right
foreign
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the co-anchor of fox and friends the
host of the Brian Kilmeade radio show
the host of One Nation on Fox News and a
New York Times best-selling author Brian
Kilmeade Brian finally welcome to the
Reuben report
that is quite a resume you know
sometimes we bring on guests it could be
a kind of thin resume I got to get to it
easily but you do a lot of stuff and I
think that's uh point being driven home
by the fact that I think you're standing
right now like you gotta go in a second
right now I prefer the standing desk and
I know you talk about these guys with
thin resumes it's because you're talking
about Joe Rogan right that guy doesn't
really do much and you have trouble
finding a reason to interview him yes
he's not doing much out there but you
have like 87 shows people see you all
the time you also you're on Gutfeld all
the time you're guest hosting on every
other show you're yeah we're doing the
show together all that good stuff but
I'm curious I actually don't know a ton
about you beyond your your Fox life I
was curious just a little bit about like
history childhood growing up what got
you into this this crazy media situation
so Dave it's really none of your
business so uh I just want you to back
off the personal questions sorry this is
Sparkle Walters I mean what's going on
here we want to make you cry by the end
of this thing you know yes I am I am
crying uh inside
um basically I uh
play to it my big thing was growing up I
was a big time soccer player wanted to
be great wasn't my whole uh family uh my
whole town went to college played uh
soccer and post but the whole time by
the time I got to college it was pretty
clear Not only was it was wasn't there a
pro league but I wasn't nearly in the
conversation with anything like that
although all my friends were which is
certainly humbling and then I always
wanted to do radio TV really since ninth
grade and that's what I was always
pushing for whether it was at the campus
radio station or interning at NBC
um doing the history of late night
television is my senior project uh I've
got an interview with Letterman when I
was still in college
not for a job but actually for the air
for radio oh wow and that's what I
wanted to do and I went right took all
that momentum and all that drive and
went right to Bennigan's where I kept
waitering right after college
trying to get that first job so I
started my own local show got a bunch of
sponsors got a limo deal got a clothing
deal wow I got a catering deal uh we got
a little sponsor money built a set and
realized because in our business was it
was pre-podcast days if you don't have a
tape you're not going to get a job they
don't care about your school your grades
so I was able to get a tape then work on
my accent uh started doing stand-up
along the way because that'll be an
opportunity that no one could deny you
there's always a stage to go up on even
if it's a terrible one in the middle of
a diner at 5 8 5 p.m so it'd be a great
way to get composure and be able to
react to an audience and then went out
to LA and got a job at a TV station
doing all sports radio on the weekends
and doing stand-up probably making
twenty seven thousand dollars all in all
uh-huh you know I remember I was getting
paid 596 every two weeks to do to work
in TV at uh which was these what happens
is these the Home Shopping Network
bought a bunch of stations so they can
get on cable and to have just get on
they had to form their own new service
so I'd go in there with a one news
director and two people and we do all
the copy do all the interviews do all
the booking so it was a great way to get
experience and then got a job uh back
here in New York or 35 000 a year doing
uh Sports
and I was doing that and it was great to
be home the only thing bad about it
after three months I got fired the new
guy they hired was actually the anchor
masquerading as the news director the
news director became the sports guy and
then I'm out of a job
and then was able to to claw my way back
into new sport get an interview with fox
in 96 started filling in and I've been
able to hold on to the job ever since I
got extremely lucky after 12 years yeah
that's what they always say it's an
overnight success but where the hell
were you for those first you know 12 15
20 years do you miss a little bit of
that kind of I didn't realize that you
had started a bunch of things yourself
and all that and as you said before
podcasting do you miss a little of that
grind because you're in a pretty smooth
system right now when I whenever I do
anything with Fox and I saw you at the
Patriot Awards it's like Fox just does a
nice job of programming and it's good
and it works and it's yeah do you miss
any of that the message a couple of
things that I was able to do you know
like the scramble when you're out on
your own like you're doing when you're
going through speaking events you get
people there the I have a little of that
with the book so when the books come out
it's up to us to charge something that
fox is going to okay that allows us to
go do personal appearances and you try
to get out there to different uh
theaters or different events Sweden even
breweries and you try to get 500 people
there to do a book signing or you go to
a theater and you try to get between 500
and 1200 people there and I'll talk
about all my books at once so that's a
little of the grind and the
entrepreneurship but within the one
thing at Fox I think you picked up
you know Fox and Friends is a machine
but within those interviews if I have
Dave Reuben one-on-one I do what I want
and I talk to the producers if I have um
you know Trey Gowdy has a book out or
what Mike Pompeo is a book out you know
confer with the producers but pretty
much you do what you want but that's a
machine like Fox and Friends is a logo
for a reason it's going to be successful
with or without
out no matter who it is they'll get the
right people in there because they know
exactly what they want but the radio
show I feel as though within that three
hours I could do what I want
you know there's people that we can't
book because it's you know I'm not going
to see if Anderson Cooper is available
uh you know the rivals but for the most
part you do what you want and then on
the weekend show I really feel like the
Saturday show at eight Eastern is it's
kind of my thing with great producers
and everyone collaborates so within this
great machine the New York Yankees
before anyone knew they were the New
York Yankees you can be yourself so
that's the grind a little bit and I just
feel so relieved every day so Dave we
meet so many talented people that don't
have great jobs even though they're
great so a lot of it is opportunity and
the only thing I'm going to give myself
credit for is knowing how great this
opportunity was and not thinking there
was something uh the grass was greener
because I after those 12 years and
talking to people while I'm here I know
the grass is not greener
you know it's interesting because you
know I feel like I know you pretty well
a little bit off camera but most mostly
on camera and through radio and all that
kind of stuff and we've been doing this
for eight or ten minutes you haven't
said anything about politics and I
wonder are do you consider yourself
really like a political animal or more
of a TV animal
uh I mean if you ask me uh Brian format
a show you don't have to you know Fox
just wants a show I love I love the
politics of it I was glad to leave
Sports I got like business you know it's
good to like a team again when you do
Sports I don't know how the other people
feel but after a while it was a job I
wasn't really enjoying going to games
yeah the Mets were playing 7 30 tonight
you can go cover the game like aren't
you a mad family yeah but
you know I I don't really need to go
deal with the traffic go back and forth
it took the fun out of it so but I love
doing the politics I love it because
it's a lot like sports as you know
what's the strategy what are you going
to do to support it you know so instead
of fans you got money to support the
candidate and then you have the issues
and besides the issues uh what are you
gonna do to get out the vote there's so
many different elements that I'm into so
you have these great candidates but
couldn't get their message out great
candidates that couldn't get any support
and then the phenomenon of trump which
no one's ever going to figure out uh
whether you'll love them or hate him no
one's ever seen anything like this
and that to me
to be able to go talk to Trump and get a
chance to meet these people
and you know and get a chance to
interact with people that make decisions
that affect the future of a country
to me I love that stuff I mean I love
foreign policy the most to me I I love
it like when Pompeo comes in
uh and Condoleezza Rice comes in or any
uh any president comes in vice president
I love diving into relationships what's
erdogan like you know what's going on
with the tanks what do you mean Germany
doesn't want to get what's so good about
their the leopard tank why can't we all
you need jetful for the Abrams so I love
that stuff so I think maybe
um I did I thought my easiest way in was
sports but my sustainability I think is
my is is I'm so into it like I can't
wait to open up the notes for Fox and
Friends at three in the morning and they
have every major thing that happened and
all the sound bites that stood out from
all the nighttime shows and some of the
daytime shows I can't wait to kind of
file that together and assemble help
assemble the radio show and give my
pitches for the TV show so I love that
stuff you know it's funny you'll
appreciate this I I wanted when I was in
college to be a sports center anchor
that that's what I thought I was going
to be you know that's why I didn't see
that that's when it you know it was the
Big Show with Keith olberman and and Dan
Patrick Overman obviously went
completely insane but that's what I
wanted to do I guess I didn't quite do
that but just like you I kind of did
something similar but first you're
saying you're a Mets fan now we're of a
similar age so the question is and I'm
from New York too where were you on game
six 1986 you have to remember
yes uh game six I was literally at
Bennigan's and I did the daytime shift
and we stood there and we roped off an
area still wearing my khaki shorts and
my collared shirt and we stood there and
watched it and then I I was able to go
to game seven you were at game seven
yeah wow guess how we got in pre-911
not proud of this but I am kinda We
snuck in we waited for the big crowd and
we went in between the turn stops wow
and I was able to get into the stadium
and sit on the steps and watch it how
crazy is that man they I mean that they
would never let that fly these days but
oh no you'd be arrested absolutely yeah
I
was in Syosset Long Island I was 10
years old having a having a sleepover
with my buddy John I will never forget
that ball going right through Buckner's
legs and the rest is history as they
said right you thought that we'd have a
championship in 87 and then 88
the drugs and hit he's just guts and
womanizing I remember one time Dwight
Gooden came into Bennigan's because it's
very close it's on the way to the
stadium and he sat by himself
by himself in that three Long Island
Iced Teas now he wasn't pitching but
they had a game that night you don't
drink a Long Island iced tea unless you
want to be drunk and I'm like wait a
second
why would you want to be drunk and watch
a game clearly there was an issue there
uh and we watched these guys go in and
out of Smithers for a few years that was
educational
right exactly for those that don't
understand the Long Island Iced Tea
basically has every liquor known to man
so if you drink Liquors yeah if you're
drinking three of those you're in
trouble let me ask you something you
mentioned you mentioned the Trump thing
and how that kind of flipped everything
on its head what was that like kind of
going from you know you're doing you're
doing Fox and Friends you're doing the
morning show all that stuff and things
are kind of normal or at least old
school the way we thought politics was
then everything just kind of get blown
apart and now and now we're in whatever
it is we're in now this kind of post
Trump I don't even mean that politically
but just where media has just been
completely blown apart
well I know that he did destroy every
Network and he tries to destroy us
thankfully he hasn't yeah because they
built something sustainable at Fox it's
going to withstand any candidate even
though you know after the election the
fact that we said the other guy won he
tried to blow us up and it definitely
hurt the ratings
um
what was it like I said to myself the
whole time why don't why can't he win
like I don't get it and when I saw him
come to the debate and do the opposition
research on everyone on that stage and
go after the leader first Jeff this
guy's into winning I mean this guy is
going to win why can he and then to be
on CNN the next day on a phone or MSNBC
the next day on a phone her I watched
him dominate the media cycle but what
people don't appreciate
is that politicians don't answer the
question
he was the first in a long time to
almost answer every question McCain was
very Barry Goldwater they say and I read
his books was very Brusque you know and
very direct McCain was kind of direct
you know they write that Harry Truman
was direct but Trump would take
everything literally take everything he
did it on our show for eight years
minimum once a week
and Ollie was here come up and go what's
going on he'd say we give him three
topics very rare for him to say I don't
want to talk about that and I'm saying
that's a guy that doesn't care but now
he's running for election and he had the
same attitude so he he ratcheted up the
game for everyone if you're given out
wrote lines like uh you know the the
same catchphrases you weren't going to
work against Trump so I think he changed
that put everyone on the defensive
you know Hillary Clinton so there's no
would hit her neither does Jeb Bush no
it didn't I was with Jeb Bush last month
and I still think to a degree I like him
too he's a great person whether you
voted for him or not
um he's still rattled so we've never
seen anything like Trump or since and I
don't think being a bully is it it's not
being a bully if there's something about
the directness where he's a rich guy his
whole life but yet most of the people
that like him aren't rich and never will
be so I've never seen it like and you
could say well he's Rich well the rich
people don't like him if you talk to
Rich successful people they didn't want
any part of trump they go because Rich
successful people aren't that outgoing
and Brash and brag at braggadocio and
the way he handled things he goes we're
not like that we have more money than
Trump
and so he connected with a whole part of
the audience no one expected and they
certainly don't eat steak well done with
ketchup that seems to be the uh the main
issue right I did not know does he have
ketchup oh yeah steak well done with
ketchup that that's the thing that he's
doing at Mar-A-Lago or wherever else
he's eating these days
um you mentioned the thing about how he
sort of tried to burn the place down or
he was angry at Fox over things do you
worry about that sometimes because it's
interesting I find on Fox there is a
plurality of opinion you know Tucker is
always bringing on people to argue with
and that really isn't happening on the
other cable channels you know they'll
bring in sort of like a fake
conservative to basically agree with
them but are you worried at times when
you guys are doing the shows that you
know a certain segment of your audience
might be angry at you at this or you got
to get them back or all of that kind of
stuff well Dave I'll tell you I go in
truth social yeah by the way I've I've
talked to Trump maybe uh more recently
than ever same guy
um but I don't agree with them I don't
agree with the pulling out of our troops
out of Syria and abandoning the Kurds I
don't agree with the down uh way we're
pulling out of Afghanistan at the time I
didn't want 5 000 troops but I thought
1200 was fine I disagree with him
um on a few things and he didn't like
that but I think he respected it but the
audience goes crazy especially early
when you disagree with what the
president's doing that you know General
Mattis is not a bad General it's not a
good thing to say I like people that
didn't get captured doesn't mean I hate
Trump but I am not going to pretend to
saying that about John McCain was right
and the whole audience were crazy I go
in truth social just to you know I'll
put something up there once in a while
or cut and paste them my Show's coming
up 50 of the comments are negative to me
uh because if you say anything against
Trump but who in your life
do you agree with 100 of the time and
you're not lying not even myself right
yeah you evolved the thing that's cool
about Fox is they never tell you what to
say you forget your own research got
your own brain room I will tell you I am
all for whatever it takes for Ukraine
maybe you're not I know Tucker is not
yeah I don't think Laura is not sure
about Sean
but I don't think it matters no one said
to me agree with Tucker and Tucker's
certainly not checking with me but he
has insightful things to say to back up
what he says so that's called a debate
that's called I watched four hours of
fox and I learned a couple of uh a
couple of sides of a debate you know and
we and it's not no one's personal I I
hope Tucker's not mad at me by
vehemently disagree
about Ukraine well my guess is he my
guess is he's not mad at you and you
guys still manage at least at the TV
level it seems like everyone kind of
likes each other I've been on Gutfeld
with you where Tucker will call in or
you know when they do the transitions
between shows you guys are messing
around last time I saw you I mean
Gutfeld was hitting you hard and you
were going right back at him it's all
done in fun and that's very different
than what goes on on the other channels
like when lemon used to have to hand it
off to Cuomo or whichever which way it
was and it was like man you guys really
hate each other
well a couple of things Cuomo and Don
Lemon were best friends you're my buddy
and the minute Cuomo started blowing up
Don lemon's like why is he still here
yeah so yeah so that is like the that's
the problem with CNN they're not real
that's not real whatever it is it's real
like so if you have a disagreement on
the five
The Producers want to make sure it
doesn't get personal it keeps it on the
issues but I'm telling you I go I'm
gonna do the five on Thursday I did the
five last Thursday
you disagree with Geraldo whatever no
one's saying you don't disagree right
and that's just it you know what I think
it is Dave you do the same thing it's a
slice of life
so you go in there and you might argue
with your best friend sometimes but the
thing is you are a responsibility to do
is research and if you know the players
make the call and if you could text
somebody say what were you thinking
about in that gun legislation and
Senator John Corning got back to me and
said Brian let me tell you exactly what
I'm thinking let me tell you what my red
line is so when I go sit on that couch
I'll say I'll either say it directly
unless they tell me to I'll say Senator
John cornyn's view is this
when I said I'll have my own opinion but
I'll do my own research so that's called
hustle mistake so if you if I end up
being wrong about something it's not
because I'm winning it and I think most
anchors here are like that I mean look
at Greg you realize to come up with
those opinions how well ready has to be
on those issues and then knowing that
he's watching the show watching the
Channel all week and he's going okay
everyone's saying the same thing I gotta
be different
and I got to offer that at 11 o'clock
whether it's at the 5 or 11 you know
when he tapes at 6 30. so
I just think that people understand here
it's like having a paper due every day
on four different topics all that being
said does Geraldo believe some of this
stuff come on absolutely yeah I mean
here's a way of being controversial but
at the other day he hopped on
and just said about the about the
classified documents in in Biden's Place
said nobody cares it's not a big deal of
course people care you know how could
you say that I know you might know you
might think it's
not going to solve the economic problems
but you think about the hypocrisy the
way he took it how the fact that he has
these these classified documents where
they'll they'll put a Marine in jail
yeah but the president can have 35
documents and you can raid the former
president's house but ask permission on
his don't tell me that's not an
unbelievable story but that's how he
feels there's one thing about Geraldo
he's got so much practical first-hand
experience and he also fundamentally
wants people to get along
I think he looks at his life he
experienced more in 10 years than I will
in 10 lifetimes and I think at this
point in his life he wants everyone to
come together but it's impossible
yeah it's just not it's not a reality
let me ask you something else off off
politics and TV for a sec you guys are
in New York uh I grew up in New York
lived in Manhattan most of my adult life
um when I go back to New York it is not
the same New York anymore uh you know
where you guys are midtownish you don't
see a lot of business people anymore it
seems like it's kind of barren and a lot
of barricades what what do you think's
going on over there do you think did you
think that Adams maybe was going to be a
little bit better than de Blasio like
what's the state of the city right now
I think uh I think Adams is 50 maybe 70
better than de Blasio number one he
cares number two is I think that um
it is definitely dangerous and the main
reason is not so much not only do we not
have enough cops none of them have been
empowered the quality the qualified
immunity is not there
they're not making the small arrests
shoplifting you basically can shoplift
now and if I'm a small business owner
you are now in bodegas locking the stuff
down this is totally fixable it's not
that gangs have taken over New York
criminals have the same 300 commit
something like the same 30 000 crimes
it's all fixable but the problem is
Albany Albany is a super majority to the
left and they don't have to deal with
the crime and the danger that Adam klotz
or meteorologist dealt with over the
weekend watch guy get beat up you step
in and you get beat up by eight guys and
the guys that get caught don't even get
detained
that's the problem there's no hell to
pay for the hell they're causing but why
is that why is that an Albany thing and
not directly a city thing related to
Adams and what he's doing he can't
reverse the no cash bail law and he
can't the judges have no discretion on
if they can prosecute or not so you come
in well if it's a certain crime I don't
care what you did you're out on your own
you've got to appear again in a certain
amount of time so everything's knocked
down they don't want to put they're
trying to close Rikers Island so there's
nowhere to put people
and you literally have somebody who's
arrested the person who was arrested
breaking into Al Pacino's House was
arrested some like 37 times for
break-ins I mean that person would have
been twice maybe once they would have
gone away so if you're a cop really I
got to worry about if I see somebody who
might be a minority and I'm a white guy
and I see something going on there and I
see all the iPhones rolling
do I want to risk my life for 35
000 a year and get sued and have my
whole family brought through the mud
unless it's something big I'm not going
to get that involved but you see how
easy it would be to get everybody in
their front foot again but I do think
Adams Elise gets it and they have they
have a lot of pride in putting him down
he went up twice to Albany to say you
got to change cash by law they basically
tell them don't come back
so I mean I do think he cares
um I I do still have hope
Brian I got one more for you because I
know you're a busy guy you got 87 shows
to do is the rumor true that Greg
Gutfeld will be playing a munchkin in
the remake of Wizard of Oz
nope you know why because there's too
many others if it was a story
and ruling over other munchkins he would
never be a part of a class or an
understudy he would never get best
supporting actor he would have uh best
leading actor without any supporting
actor over and over again so he'd have
to be the center of attention
um Now Greg Greg's story is pretty
phenomenal I was I was pretty stunned to
see uh listen to uh Joe Rogan talk about
it because the outside of perspective
because I consider you part of us if you
hope you don't mind
Both Worlds I I love it I love doing the
fox stuff and I love doing the Rogan
stuff it's it's Both Worlds that I get
to see and be part of yeah right and he
has no idea like the the people let's
say but he's just talking about and he's
a comedian and he's saying how The
Tonight Show used to have everything
that's no doubt why gutfeld's most
successful is there any doubt the reason
why he's most successful is it's normal
guys talking about funny stuff nobody
everybody else is just is left comedy
and is now like a new show with a point
of view with people that can't ask
questions and Gutfeld is a real show you
actually laugh I watched the cold open
of SNL with Fox Sports
and I said this is like bad for a high
school variety show are they even
rehearsing
it's horrible and that's why Greg Greg
deserves a lot of credit because it's
the same show he's doing on red eye you
know and he just kept doing it kept
doing it at midnight uh it was getting
great ratings and now he's killing it on
being himself
on Saturday but it really is that simple
when when we did the uh the Fox Nation
thing a couple weeks ago we're about to
start the show remembering Greg turns to
me and he said that he had diarrhea and
then I was like I'm gonna use that
during the show and then you'd roll with
it and everybody's laughing and you're
giving him crap about it no pun intended
and that's what it's all about
how are we ending on crap and Gutfeld
give me something you're you're a TV
host and the show professionally please
hey I'm gonna end the show
professionally let me see
um Dave you're a deep thinker who also
could do stand up and does it uh you do
it all and somehow you find time to get
a slice of my life I am honored to be
asked to be on uh thanks so much and
promise me next time and there will be a
next time don't bring up Greg Gutfeld
there will be no gut fell next time kill
me you're a true Pro I hope to see you
in person soon and uh now get back to
work sayasu misses you
if you're looking for more uncensored
opinions from today's thought leaders
check out our media playlist and if you
want to watch full interviews on a wide
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell